hey everyone I'm Walter Binet dziak and
this is top five here we countdown the
best and worst performances of our most
beloved actors we're doing something a
little bit different today and next week
we're doing our very first top 10 best
will go through numbers 10 through 6
right now and count down the top 5 best
next week why because I think this actor
deserves it it's the one and only Robin
Williams this is probably my most
requested subject and I totally
understand why Robin Williams was a
legend an actor the likes of which this
world will never see again
he had performances to his name that
could make you fall on the floor
laughing openly weep or both the purpose
of an actor is to make you feel an
emotion there were very few that can do
this in such a wide variety like this
guy could Williams won one Oscar and was
nominated for three others in his career
a career filled with at the very least
memorable performances it's been a
little over two years since Robin passed
away and that wound is still pretty
fresh for a lot of people I think it's
important that we remember what a truly
unique talent he was so let's kick off
this super-sized list these are the top
10 best performances from mr. Robin
Williams number 10
Walter Finch in insomnia this 2002
Christopher Nolan movie is often glossed
over when discussing his filmography it
teams up Al Pacino and Robin Williams in
a film that's been a bit forgotten a
remake of the 1997 Norwegian film of the
same name insomnia follows the story of
La Detective will dormer as he is sent
to a small Alaskan town to investigate
the killing of a high school girl once
their events set in motion an intricate
game with the killer that asks many
moral questions both of dormer and the
murderer himself Williams plays the bad
guy here as he's often proved that he
could do and he leaves all the jokes at
the door for a seriously good underrated
performance we don't even hear his voice
until about 49 minutes in and we don't
see his face until even later the film
builds his character up and the mystery
surrounding him results in a presence
created by Williams that is pretty heavy
for the rest of the film
they never look in the eyes of a killer
killing changes you you know that it's
not guilt I never meant to it
it's like quits he plays a reclusive and
anti-social writer turned killer hearing
him describe the murder is pretty
bone-chilling
he makes excuses that paint his
character all the more unstable yet
still strangely calm she's terrified
she's screaming her head off I put my
hand over a mouth and the venom I'm
really scared I'm like scared shitless
more scared than I've ever been now and
you know I am more scared than her
Pacino and Williams have some nice
chemistry in their tit-for-tat scenes
that ends up being the core of the story
and moral dilemma combine that with some
seriously effective action scenes from
the two stars and you have something
unique enough to check out number nine
Peter banning slash Peter Pan in Hook
for me when I think of Robin Williams my
mind immediately goes to a couple films
this is one of them what if Peter Pan
grew up that's the question at the crux
of this Steven Spielberg directed film
when his children are kidnapped by
Captain Hook Peter must return to
Neverland and rescue them
the problem is Peter banning has no
memory of his life as Peter Pan once
their Tinker Bell and the Lost Boys try
to get Peter back in flying shape to
finally defeat Hook and retrieve his
kids I think this film holds up pretty
darn well and I'm not even wearing
nostalgia goggles although I'm sure it
looks even better with them on
it's wrong
oh my god this was one of the films I
got a little emotional watching Robyn's
performance coupled with John Williams
criminally underrated score really
brought out a lot of mixed feelings in
me Robin starts off as Peter banning a
cold selfish man who drinks too much
seeing how he slowly discovers who he
was is handled really well by Williams
he's in denial for a long time before
finally remembering his past life and
that moment will live on in my mind
forever
you
this film is filled with amazing moments
and other great performances from the
late Bob Hoskins mr. Smith - Dante
Bosco's Rufio - Dustin Hoffman's titular
Captain Hook I hate I hate I hate Pete
ah Pat Williams manages to sneak in a
few of his trademark ad-libs -
nearsighted gynecologist an aspect I
don't think a lot of people talk about
is how well Williams portrays his
relationship with his kids specifically
his young son Jack there's a lot behind
his eyes in those scenes you feel his
pain and pride sometimes at the same
time it was you
hi jack
my dad please don't ruin this of course
when Peter once again becomes the pan we
see a lot of great stuff he's such a
natural fit as this character even at
that age pan the Avenger is back
I know hook is waiting you killed Rufio
kidnap my children we just have to die
strike to pan strike true there is a
line at the end of this film that is
delivered so perfectly after Robyn's
death I probably went back and watched
this clip a dozen times it's bittersweet
now but it's still very very special to
me to live to live will be an awfully
big adventure
number eight Alan Parrish in Jumanji
what year is it Sarah Whittle run they
just did beat so now I would like to get
out of the floor so it's your turn Peter
just a few of the memorable moments and
lines from Jumanji Rock I love you don't
mess this up a mysterious board game
releases a whirlwind of dangerous
adventure Peter and Judy Shepard just
moved into the abandoned mansion of the
Parrish family after hearing loud drums
they find an old board game in the Attic
and upon a few rolls of the dice Alan
Parrish is released from the game after
being in prison 26 years earlier with
Kaos and suing around them Judy Peter
Allen and his old friend Sarah Whittle
must finish the game so everything can
go back to normal this is based on the
1981 fantasy children's picture book by
Crispin Ellsberg Joe Johnston director
of The Rocketeer and Captain America the
First Avenger was also behind this movie
it's another classic Robin Williams film
from the 90s that a lot of kids at that
time have fond memories of Williams
leads the charge with the performance
that ranges from manic to successfully
sentimental upon his release from the
jungles of Jumanji Allen has to react to
being back in his child at home and all
the things he's missed those are
actually some great scenes and not just
for a kids movie the bear she's still
around I see no none
they're over on Adams Street
allons time in the game also changes his
outlook on things and honestly he can
get a little creepy I've seen things
you've only seen in your nightmares
things you can't even imagine things you
can't even see there are things that
aren't you in the night something
screams then you hear them and you hope
to god - you're not desert other
enjoyable facets to this character
include reconnecting with his friend
Sarah who he started playing the game
with as a boy and how he deals with
Peter Allen's father wasn't very
affectionate to him and you see that
come out at certain points towards the
younger of the two Shepherd siblings you
have a problem you face it like a man
Hey
I'm sorry 26 years buried with deepest
darkest jungle and I still became my
father in fact it's that relationship
Alan has with his father that is the
heart of the movie when Van Pelt comes
out of the game we see a direct
connection as the same actor who plays
Alan's dad also plays this crazed hunter
my father told me you should always face
what you're afraid of good lad
you're finally acting like a man does
anyone remember the cartoon show because
I remember liking that as well this is
still a fun watch all these years later
give it a view with the kids I think the
whole family can get something out of it
number seven the genie in Aladdin 10,000
years will give you such a crick in the
neck this is the first time I've been
able to talk about a vocal performance
on the show and I think this is the
perfect one to cover it's maybe Williams
most iconic performance and you never
even see his face when poor young thief
Aladdin finds a lamp in the Cave of
Wonders he releases the all-powerful
genie and with him three wishes pining
for the affection of Princess Jasmine is
Aladdin's main concern but when Jafar
the evil Royal vizier to the Sultan
takes the lamp for himself
a land must come up with a way to set
things right and save the kingdom of
Agrabah
I hadn't seen Aladdin in years and oh
man does it hold up the animation is
fantastic and the cast of characters in
this movie are all great they're
utilized perfectly the music is of
course top-notch I loved friend like me
but my favorite song in the Latin is
Prince Olly
heard your princess was a sign lovely to
see
and that's the people is why we got
known Duncan drop god I can't even keep
up with all the great jokes and
impersonations Williams throws into the
genie he was on another level here I
can't bring people back from the dead
it's not a pretty picture I can't
believe it
I'm losing to a rug all right Sparky
here's the deal if you want to court the
little lady you gotta be a straight
shooter - you got it
the Jeannie character became a
phenomenon after the release of a Latin
it's 100% a trademark Robin Williams
performance complete with some really
great emotion sprinkled into it no
matter what anybody says
you'll always be a prince to me if you
have a chance I'd say buy the blu-ray
and check out the genie outtakes for
unheard improv from Williams to leave
you even more in awe of what an amazing
accomplishment this character was number
six airman second class Adrian Cronauer
in good morning Vietnam Williams was
nominated for an Oscar for his
performance here and he gets to really
cut loose in those radio broadcast
scenes he seems totally unfiltered in
this one when funny man Adrian Cronauer
is sent to Vietnam he brings with him
his aney radio broadcast antics his new
show lifts the morale of the troops but
offends his superior officers outside
his show cron hour befriends some of the
locals and even pursues a relationship
with one things turn serious when Adrian
finds out a dark secret about one of his
friends I'll just let some of the speak
for itself
hey wait a minute let's try something
let's play this backwards and see if it
gets any better well there's me if
Freddie is a devil look this nivea
freddie is a devil oh no no Nana Nana
Nana Nana picture a man going on a
journey beyond sight and sound he's left
Crete he's entered the Demilitarized
Zone the whole movie Williams is very
sharp maybe as sharp as I've ever seen
him one liners are all over the place
it's almost non-stop well I'm actually
giving you an order
oh it's an order that case gentlemen
let's head it
we know Robin handled serious moments
very well and he did so here in a few
great scenes what are you afraid of
dickerson people might find out there's
a war but this news is not official
airman you want everyone going the
assumption is perfectly safe here don't
you well it's not the fight it's not
just in the hills it's downtown it's a
couple exact it is none of your goddamn
business this movie isn't one of my
favorites from him but Robin was
fantastic here and more than enough to
keep you entertained check it out if you
want to see Williams really go all out
with his lightning fast humor Plaza made
you look I'll be back next week with
Robins top five best performances until
then I want to hear what you guys think
what is your favorite Robin Williams
performance or movie who you want me to
cover next in the show leave a comment
and let me know follow me on Twitter at
awesome underscore Walter to take part
in more polls about who I may cover in
the future see you next week
you